bonjour à tous bienvenue dans le résumé
des rondes 7 et 8 du match de
championnat du monde dans cette septième
partie de ce car celle doubler les
couleurs et ils prenaient les blancs
pour la deuxième fois après avoir essayé
la plupart des premiers coups des cats
pour commencer ses quatre ans 8 et 4
pour finir il revient finalement
peut-être sur son cou préféré qui est un
des quatre voici la position dans
laquelle nous aboutissions aux 13e coup
les noirs viennent de prendre le pion en
c4 on s'attendait probablement à la
reprise du pion avec le chou en c4 tout
simplement et les blancs ont préféré
jouer le coup qui a validé deux
certainement un bon coup pour récupérer
plutôt le pion avec le cavalier qu'est
ce qui se serait passé si le fou avait
pris probablement les noirs avaient
prévu de chasser le dangereux coup j'ai
cinq ans avec le coup hachey ce parce
que le clouage sur le cavalier 6 était
quand même assez gênant flash 4 pour
conserver ce clouage hélas les noirs ou
une jolie manoeuvre cavalier e 5 pour
attaquer le foot c quatre et par la
suite
bref au deux cavaliers g6 finalement
pour chasser le fou h4 donc dans la
partie magnus carlsen joie 14 cavaliers
d2 et après une longue réflexion de la
part de son adversaire
celui ci joue à cavalier e 5
probablement un bon coup donc pour venir
protéger le pion c4 est tout simplement
échanger lecavalier si celui ci arrive
en c4 et prend ses 4 l'idée principale
en fait c'est de jouer sur les pièces
qui vont être non protégé après le coup
cavaliers prend ses quatre cavaliers
prend ses quatre fous prend ces quatre
là les deux fous des blancs ne sont pas
protégés et la dame noire pourrait les
attaquer en un coup en jour dames c'est
5 à ce moment là les fous seront obligés
de se sauver en prenant le cavagnan f6
avait plus fous g5
mais là
noir prendrait le fou en ckd pour ne pas
doubler les pions du roi et les noirs
obtiendra la paire de fouet en plus la
dame en c4 est bien placé pour empêcher
le pétrole des blancs donc la pollution
blanche est plutôt mauvaise ici donc
après le coup ko 5 sagement maintenu
carson a préféré faire le petit rock il
y avait une variante qui était quand
même assez intéressante peut être à
jouer avec les blancs c'était le coup
cavaliers c'est en quatre pour jouer sur
ce cavalier un f6 cloué et essayer de
doubler les pions devant le roi noirs
les blancs qui avec un pion de moins ont
préféré jouer de façon plus sûre qu'est
ce qui se serait passé sur quel essai le
cadre par exemple fou 17 pour lier les
tours l'a peut-être le ku'damm ces trois
étaient pas mal jouant sur le cavalier
non protégés 1 au 5 mai il y avait une
variante un peu forcée avec le coup
cavaliers pro 4 même si le cavalier clou
il peut quand même prendre le cavaly
parce qu'ils attaquent la dame ainsi le
fou blanc prend la dame en recettes le
cavalier noir prendrait la dame en c3
est ici par exemple ou fawcett vous
prenez la tour en fuite
il y aurait le coup cavaliers prend à
eux deux et l'a probablement les noirs
obtiendrait quand même un avantage dans
cette position donc après le coup
cavaillé c'est le cas tu fous des sept
dames ces trois cavaliers prend le 4 il
n'y aurait pu suivre par exemple
cavaillé prend 2 4 pour les blancs f6
pour éviter la taxe sur la dame mais
aussi pour essayer de défendre le
cavalier mais sur f6 lire le coût d'un
prend 1,5
un joli coup puisque si le pub 9,6 prend
la dame en rose 5 la dame recette est
perdu et des blancs on voit une pièce
davance mais les noirs peuvent prendre
le fou en g5 avec leurs pions et
conservant un pion de rld avance mais
après fou simple pensée 4 les blancs
auraient repris ce pion
ce qui se serait passé finalement elle
et nous avons quand même des
affaiblissements le pion aux 6es isolé
il ya des puits en double est alors on
peut jouer à chis évidemment pour
défendre le plan g5 les noirs ont quand
même là car de flou dans cette position
relativement ouverte donc c'est une
compensation pour la mauvaise structure
de pions mais ça semblait quand même une
position intéressante elle joué pour les
blancs donc le kuga et ce4 il a été joué
le coup petit rock 15e coup et après fou
17 les blancs auraient pu de nouveau
probablement joué le coup cavaliers ce4
pour obtenir un petit peu le même genre
de situation où tout à l'heure peut-être
un petit peu moins favorable parce que
les noirs ont la possibilité de le tour
à 6,8 et sur dame ces trois cavaliers
prend 1,4 cavaillé prend le cadre f6
dame prend 1,5
hélas les noirs ont le coin intervenir
fous ces sept qui attaquent la dame
il force donc la dame a bougé et
seulement après les noirs pourront
prendre le fou angers 5 sachant que
d'autres ont ces huit n'est pas si mal
placé la paire de fous des noirs est
quand même relativement intéressante
en tout cas encore une position
intéressante à jouer pour les blancs
finalement maintenue carson a préféré
jouer un coup
un peu plus solide il a joué 16 fois f4
pour attaquer le cavalier mais après
cavaillé g6 fou j'ai trois fous ces 6 on
voit pas trop calé sur l avantage des
blancs étant donné que les pièces noir
commencent à sortir très facilement la
partie et continuer ainsi cavaillé prend
ses quatre peut-être pour viser un petit
peu la casse des six pouces et 7
tous rêvent d un on va passer rapidement
sur tous les échanges il y avoir des
échanges de tours et puis ensuite
quelques échanges de pièces après
qu'elle ait pensé 3 voilà encore un fou
qui s'échangent on se retrouve
finalement assez rapidement en finale au
26e coup après le courroux des trois
peut-être que l'idée des blancs serait
de prendre le cavaillon g6 et tenté de
jouer une finale avec le koup dame qui
avait les pondre dame fou c'est que
c'est un petit peu supérieure
normalement d'avoir la dame et le
cavalier contre la dame et le fou les
deux pièces vont mieux ensemble et là on
y avait un joli coup pour les noirs qui
semblait faire nul assez rapidement on
va forcer la nulle en tout cas c'était
le coup fougue 4 parce que si le
football en prenait ce fonds de 4 il y
avait un échec perpétuel avec des échecs
roitg de damas cinq échecs et leurs
robes longues ne pouvait pas s'enfuir et
bien sûr le fou blanc n'était pas obligé
de prendre le flou car il pouvait y
avoir une petite contre pointe avec le
coup cavalli ou 5 qui était amusant
parce qu'après cavaliers prend 2,5 dame
bronze 5 le chou détroit bien comprise
deux fois 1 par la dame ont 17 et le
fond et 4 ne pouvait pas est pris à
cause du mat du couloir en des huit avec
la dame le fameux maître du couloir
leroy bloqué par ses trois pions mais
ici les noirs pouvaient encore je vais
le coup f5 donc pour se donner une case
pour éviter le mal du pouvoir pour
protéger le fou est aussi une autre
raison c'est bloqué la dame blanche pour
éviter qu'elles ne viennent contrôler la
case à chocs pour quelles raisons bien
pour avoir le fameux échec perpétuelle
après fou prend 1,4 d'amd un échec
rouages de
dames à chaque échec serait étaient
parties nulles tout de suite ça n'a pas
été jouée finalement fabiano caruana a
préféré jouer tranquillement le coup b6
qui est assez équilibré de toutes façons
mais ça va faire nul assez vite après f3
fougue et cette frange et 6h 3 et 6 4
les blancs vont tenter de bloquer le fou
bessette en installant aussi un forte
leur fort cavaliers en d6 mais cela ne
va pas être suffisant puisque le roi
noir va arriver très vite les noirs
attaque le défenseur du cavalier mais
les blancs au défendre mais le roi noir
la possibilité d'arriver à toute vitesse
en 17
et si le roi blonde ne vient pas tout de
suite au sylvain leroy noir irait
attaqué le pion à eux cinq ans faisant
droit sait si ces rois des cinq là
laurent blanc arrive juste à temps pour
l'empêcher mais les noirs ont la
possibilité d'attaquer avec leur fou le
seul pion sur case blanche ce qui oblige
les bleus à reculer et il va y avoir une
répétition de position et la partie a
été nul
après cela une partie assez assez
termine finalement il y aurait pu y
avoir quelque chose d'un peu plus
intéressant dans le milieu de partie
peut-être avec le coup cavalli c'est en
eux quatre on passe à la huitième partie
dans laquelle fabiano caruana avait les
blancs est toujours une sicilienne donc
toujours le coup de quatre pour fabiano
caruana peut-être on pouvait s'attendre
à ce qu'il change et finalement il a
repris le cou aux cadres et cette fois
sur les sicilienne il a joué la grande
variante la variante ouverte voilà ça
c'était ce qui ce qu'on attendait de lui
pour essayer vraiment de de prendre
l'initiative de jouer pour la victoire
aujourd'hui et il est passé pas loin de
la victoire je pense dans cette partie
grâce à une très bonne préparation
il a joué une très bonne ouverture peut
être même où personne n'avait pas
vu qu'il allait jouer ça et il se
retrouve dans une position excellente au
23e coup après le coup food et 6 des
noirs regardez le cavalier très avancées
en v6 indélogeable sur une carte forte
le pian passé en d5 le flou en c3 qui
contrôlait diagonale devant le roi noirs
les blancs avec le retour en d1 qui
soutiennent le pion passé la tour et fin
qui pourrait revenir assez rapidement
sur la colonne ouverte et la possibilité
pour la dame blanche devenir proche du
roi noir et c'est ça qu'il n'a pas fait
il a raté le coup pourtant qui semblait
vraiment évident le couvain qu'adam en
h5 un très fort coup la dame blanche qui
s'infiltrent dans le camp des noirs ont
fait une pression sur le pion g5 ici ce
qui empêche d'anouar de bouger et loi
des fonctions la dame blanche peut
menacer aussi d'avancer enrichissent
pour créer une menace de m'allonger 7
avec l'aide du fou c3 et la tour en f1
donc il pourra récupérer cette colonne
l'imposition noir était vraiment
extrêmement compromise après ce coup
d'un match 5 par exemple sur le coup
j'ai six pour chasser la dame simplement
la dame blanche revient ou h3 pour viser
la case 6 et si le four revient rêve 5
était qu'est la dame cette fois le
blanchir en schiste pour menacer match
une position très compliqué pour les
noirs peut-être les noirs
or elle aurait rendu leurs pions même
deux pions sur le coût d'un machin qui
saura était peut-être le meilleur coût
en jouant des 8 es sûr d'un projet cinq
échecs dames g6 là les pubs les noirs
ont rendu le pion g5 et vont
certainement perdre un deuxième pion à
près d'un projet six échecs h plongée 6
cavalli ces quatre attaquants le fou en
d6 et tord bd huit cavaliers prend des
sisters précise fu aux 5
voilà les blancs vont récupérer
finalement le pion f4 et obtenir une
finale avec un pion d' avance donc des
possibilités des bonnes possibilités de
gagner cette partie très curieusement
fabiano caruana n'a pas joué ce coude à
machin qu'en plus ce qu'ils avaient à ce
moment là de la partie 50 minutes en
plus à la pendule un puisqu'il était
vraiment dans sa préparation il avait
très vite l'ouverture et tout d'un coup
et ben probablement un mauvais coup
vraiment le coup h3 incompréhensible
coup c'est probablement pour empêcher le
coup j'ai 4 mai le coup j'ai 4 n'était
était une menace bien sûr à ce moment là
parce que ça aurait forcé éléments a
reculé mais c'est le coup tellement
évident d'un machin qui n'a pas été
jouer c'est très curieux et là
maintenant
mclouth carson a la possibilité de
sortir enfin ces pièces de leurs
positions médiocre avec le très beaucoup
d'amis 8 qui permet à la lame de revenir
maintenant sur la case angers 6 où elle
va à peu près tout protéger un du côté
roy et ça va permettre aussi à la tourbe
et 8,1 de revenir maintenant je
probablement sur la colonne peut il ya
eu qu'à voyez c'est qu'adam g 6 qui est
prôné six daims prend des six les blancs
finalement qui sont rendus compte de
leur erreur et qui joue à nouveau le
pion h en allant en h4 pour essayer de
récupérer le pion f4 par la suite mais
il y aura que simplement une égalisation
dans cette finale après gpush 4 d'un
point et adam pour les capteurs
car être voilà la position déjà être
très terne avec deux tours un fou et
cinq pions pour les blancs il ya même un
peu en avance pour les noirs mais et les
blancs vont bien sûr récupéré très
rapidement leurs pions mais avec des
foulards reposer pas grand chose à faire
on va continuer un petit peu 38e tour f6
voilà foot - m6 rev7 les blancs
finalement récupère le pion doublé mais
les noirs ont proposé les changes détour
si les blancs échange les finales de
chou est complètement égal
les blancs vont tenter à quelques coups
mais pas très longtemps tout réfléchi
croit g8 tout réussi ce tour de georgie
six échecs fuite des six tours d2 alors
un petit piège ici quand même à la fin
après d66 les l'on apprenne le pion b2
voilà le petit piège c'était que les
blancs pouvaient prendre le flou g4 avec
la tour et sur pions projet kde le pion
aller à dame
avec 17 puisque le flou en h4 contrôler
la case aux conventions c'était le
dernier petit piège mais évidemment les
noirs l'ont vu très rapidement avec le
coutour d2 le pion ne peut plus avancer
et les blanches jouaient retour g5 et
proposer proposer un nul donc une
huitième nul dans ce match pourtant ici
dans cette partie fabiano caruana avait
obtenu une bonne position mais je vous
merci d'avoir suivi ce résumé de ces
deux parties et puis je vous dis à
bientôt pour les prochains résumé